[Music]
the people whose jobs it is as
professionals or as educators or as
regulators to go deep into the details
of the workings of the financial system
I'm guessing if you ask a hundred of
them ninety-five would say were far more
resilient now than we were in 2007
dramatically so
post-crisis the dodd-frank Act does
impose additional requirements higher
capital requirements for banks when they
have these securities on their balance
sheets enormous fines to the banks for
any mis-selling of mortgage products
skin in the game requirements that
require the originators to keep a slice
of these securitizations on their own
balance sheets so that they have to eat
whatever they feed to others and these
requirements were enough to make the
market a lot safer
it's not only that they have a lot more
capital there's a lot more transparency
now so in the derivatives markets for
example most of the off-exchange
derivatives are now reported where
regulators can see them and the standard
derivatives are centrally cleared in
clearing houses where they're more
safely a risk managed in case someone
one of the largest derivatives traders
were to fail those positions would be
managed by Clearing House rather than
causing immediate contagion into the
rest of the financial system
the banks are much better capitalized
now than they were before the crisis
dramatically so and yet when they get
credit from wholesale bond investors the
bond investors are asking for much
higher compensation in yield for bearing
the risk of default losses now how do
you square those two facts first the
banks are much safer much less likely to
fail and secondly bond investors are
requiring much more compensation for
barring losses associated with bank
failure there's only one reasonable
explanation in my mind and that's the
perception by investors that were a
large US bank to get into trouble in the
future the government is not going to
bail them out the government is not
going to make those bonds whole the
difference between the likelihood that
big banks got bailed out before the
financial crisis versus the likelihood
that they will get bailed out in the
future is dramatic
it's a significant reduction in the
probability of bail out that's implied
by those market prices
imagine a very large Bank on death's
door or maybe it's just getting
undercapitalized and the government has
lost patience with the managers of the
bank and has become concerned that the
bank may fail and cause problems for the
economy now regulators have on their
dashboard a big red button called Balian
if they hit that button then the bank
will go through a failure resolution
process by which overnight the debts of
the bank are eliminated a large fraction
of them are eliminated and the creditors
that were owed those debts are no longer
creditors to the bank they are now
shareholders in the bank and they
therefore will suffer the losses that
the taxpayers might have otherwise
suffered that process is called bail in
and of course there are it's a
complicated process and it's being
implemented in different ways in
different countries but in the United
States it's taken quite seriously by
bond investors that's one of the reasons
that they no longer believe in too big
to fail is that they know that that red
button is sitting on the desk of the
regulator's waiting to be hit when the
time comes and that the plans for this
failure resolution have been fairly
methodically worked out
the day and in in which we say okay the
system is great and let's just keep it
going the way it is that that day is
still far off but in terms of the US
financial system collapsing because of a
shock like the one that occurred in 2007
it'll happen someday but it's not going
to happen nearly as frequently as as it
would have given the situation that we
faced before the financial crisis
[Music]
you
[Music]